hi my name is Vincent Staples and this
is me reviewing every [ __ ] thing
that's a meme that's great
Arthur was a great show was he your
aardvark or was he a bear that's him
about to punch somebody in the [ __ ]
face because black Twitter and Twitter
two completely different things here
come that boy oh [ __ ] what up it's a
frog on a unicycle no more to be said
girls like to say corny things on the
Internet you know how they all go to the
bathroom together that's how they act on
the internet so this is the thing that
they're doing right now so people do
they get the man that can do both things
it's a current theme right now don't
know we talked about you go back to
black Twitter that's trash black Twitter
black Twitter's an amazing place see
black Twitter has way better maybe this
is trash do you have any Latino Twitter
moves Yasmine when you're around a bunch
of black people some crazy [ __ ] about to
happen and then you get the look just
say run you just don't run it and
everybody's gonna make that face no
matter what as I was a go that's
hilarious
black Twitter one more time black people
are creative and this is black Twitter
creation [ __ ] is real I'm get you a
black Twitter account